you mentioned square and
visa sort of investing in bitcoin what
do you make of uh
probably one of the higher profile big
investments in bitcoin which is tesla
and elon musk
but there's also a few billionaires like
chamoth and all of them investing
what do you make of this whole movement
why do you think they're doing it i mean
tesla is an interesting case why do you
think tesla's putting
uh buying so much bitcoin i honestly
don't know and i would love to truly
know
elon's genuine thoughts on bitcoin um
because he's kind of sending us mixed
messages honestly
with his embrace of dogecoin which is
sort of playful
not exactly sure which one what point
he's trying to make there so you were
involved with deutsche
coin you mentioned offline a little bit
in like in the early days or at least
like
uh played around with it what do you
make of deutsche coin what do you make
of elon and doge what do you make
of this particular meme coin is it
is it one like a legitimate
cryptocurrency
or is it too like
a funny internet way of saying fu to the
man
yeah it's it's a good question i mean so
i wasn't like a figurehead in dogecoin
or anything but that was totally my
introduction to crypto was
mining dogecoin in my dorm room and then
tipping people online in dogecoin which
i just
thought was the funniest thing
so i guess that was really easy to
entertain back in 2013.
but it was very playful at the time
there was a culture around dogecoin
and the people liked it because it was
in opposition to the bitcoin culture
which was really serious
and involved lots of austrian economics
and rothbard and hayek and stuff like
that
so that was my introduction to
cryptocurrency
was because i thought the bitcoin people
were pretty lame yeah
and they were like way too serious about
all this stuff and i was like okay
i'll just be a part of the dogecoin
community and they did all these funny
publicity stunts like
they paid to send the jamaican bobsled
team to the olympics
you know like great stuff like they put
the dogecoin logo on top of a nascar car
yeah um and i just that tickled me so
much because it's like
this made up internet coin this was back
when crypto was pretty novel and still
like kind of funny and stuff
and that was really entertaining fast
forward seven eight years
dogecoin is way less entertaining now
frankly because
it's the leadership left the community
spirit
evaporated um the meme didn't persist i
mean doge
itself is not really a contemporary meme
right i mean it's an old meme
although that new refresher the meme
like doji haven't heard that name in a
long time
like where does like in a hat smoking a
cigarette
i mean there's some sense where elon is
reinvigorating the meme
and it's funny because like one
influential figure could
do just that which just speaks to the
tension that you're talking about
like tesla is investing bitcoin and yet
elon he also tweets about bitcoin but
yeah he's i mean who am i to question
the meme right like yeah i i can't
you know dissect internet culture and
pedentically sit here and tell you it's
an invalid meme
yeah you know if if people believe in it
then it's real
is there a space for meme coins at this
at this
time like like doge or somebody or
somebody else to almost like
um you know there's it does serve a lot
of purposes which is
like you said it pulls in people
into this whole space of digital
currency and the digital
in uh into cryptocurrency
allowing to explore alarm to have fun as
opposed to taking everything very
seriously
is there still space for that yeah yeah
and i mean
the crypto landscape is very broad today
so
whatever you know cultural element you
seek to find within crypto you will find
it was a bit different in 2013 because
bitcoin was kind of the only game in
town there were a couple altcoins
and so dogecoin made a lot of sense as a
counterpart to bitcoin as the less
serious counterpart
today crypto is just this like gigantic
cultural
and economic trend so it's you know very
multifaceted
dogecoin is one of the many you know
ways that people have to engage with it
i think
a lot of people that buy dogecoin based
on elon's
implied guidance are going to lose money
because
fundamentally there's nothing enduring
about dogecoin it's an ancient
fork of bitcoin it's unmaintained
they're you know it's probably at risk
actually from a protocol perspective
it's merge mined with litecoin i think
um
if there was an inflation bug on
dogecoin it's unclear who would sort of
be able to remediate that
you know so it's not technologically
very sound
um so i wouldn't recommend that anyone
stores wealth in it
you know yes it's funny because
cryptocurrency
like my interest in cryptocurrency is in
the exploration of technical ideas
but cryptocurrency is also like in the
case of dogecoin
like for laws at least
originally like a meme coin but it's
also a uh mechanism for investment
and so th those are sometimes attention
and 100 and it's unclear sort of like
yeah
you know there's the the meme with those
just almost become to take it to
i guess to a dollar trying to drive the
price of the value up to a dollar
but you know implied in that is like
this overlap of the meme coin
and like legitimate investment and so
you have a lot of young people
i think who almost
start getting greedy and want to make
money like as opposed to
uh having fun and that becomes a
different beast then because you're
essentially
making financial decisions that can have
a long lasting
like you know money is freedom
and if you make stupid financial
decisions
it you can remove freedom from your life
and that's
it could be detrimental in that sense so
i don't uh
it's difficult i don't know what to do
with that with that set of ideas because
a lot of cryptocurrency including
bitcoin is very volatile
because it's new so you're trying to
figure out the space of like
what's actually going to be a large part
of
like you speak of network effects like
what's going to take over the world
and through that process there's going
to be a lot of volatility
and if you're talking about
cryptocurrency
as a investment mechanism
then it can have a real detrimental
effects on people's lives
yeah and that's really the challenge
with operating in the crypto space
talking about it overlaid on top of
everything that's interesting
politically or culturally about it
is the financial incentive yeah and so
you know it's not all fun and games
because they're
literally billions over a trillion
dollars at stake now
so if you buy dogecoin because some
influencer on tick tock said so yeah
you've now made a financial decision
right so i'm not gonna scold any
dogecoin buyers or
any crypto asset buyer for that matter
but
be aware that there are like billions of
dollars of
really elite hedge funds that are trying
to front run
all of your decisions and evaluate
social sentiment things like that
so it's a water full of sharks basically
and by the way if you're listening to
this
don't take this podcast or anything i
ever say is financial advice that's
definitely not my interest or expertise
level
now the the interest here is to explore
different ideas
you